98% of the world's people are spending
98% of their time on things that don't
matter you have free choice always about
everything but for goodness sakes stop
making free choices and call yourself
the victim of them
wake up life will never make sense to
your mind if you're trying to get life
to make sense with your mind you might
as well forget it need motivation watch
a top 10 with believe nation what's up
at 7 my 1 word is believe and I believe
in you I believe you have an amazing
gift inside you that I want to see
exploded under the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being in a car accident and
breaking his neck to being homeless and
having to live in a tent making money by
getting recycled cans and selling them
to surviving homelessness eventually
writing the best-selling book
conversations with God and 29 books
he's Neale Donald Walsch and here's my
take on his top 10 rules to success
enjoy
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one shift your values up for the
first 50 years of my life ition I
thought that my life was about me I had
the attitude of a 10 year old or a 9
year old or a 6 year old but I had that
attitude when I was 29 or 39 I just you
know I thought that wasn't a bad person
I'm not try to paint myself is this
horrible individual but I was fairly
self-centered I was looking at my own
career my own goals my old objectives my
own needs my own wants my own desires I
tried to be even-handed about it if
somebody helped me how I tried to give
back if I could and all those things
that were taught to do but basically my
life was focused on me
fascinatingly even though my life was
focused on me virtually all the time my
life wasn't working I mean at some point
in my life I really got oh gosh I can't
seem to find happiness that lasts more
than a little while like I can't seem to
find success that lasts was it a little
while - everything is so ephemeral it
just comes in and goes out comes in and
goes out
I never seem to get anywhere to the top
of the mountain when when is to struggle
over this what I was experiencing when I
had my first conversation with God so
that's the context that's the background
why I was given that wisdom because I
asked God okay obviously there's
something here I don't understand
i I've listened to what my daddy told me
and listen to what my mommy told me I
listen to what my religion told me I
listen to what my culture told me but
there's some missing data I felt that
there was just some information that was
missing so I said to God what is it what
is it that I don't understand here the
understanding of which would change
everything God said to me Neil it's
really very simple
that she said what you just said here
Neil your life is not about you your
life is about everyone else whose life
you touch and the way in which you touch
it and I said I don't understand they
were supposed to give up everything that
I ever wanted her desired her hoped for
give up all of my goals all of my
objectives and she said no no no I
didn't say that I didn't say that
you don't have to set aside all of your
goals set aside all of your objectives
set aside all of the things to follow
your desires no I didn't say that but
it's about achieving them working toward
them moving toward them in a whole
different way for a whole different
reason if you're doing those things to
enrich the lives of everyone whose life
you touch watch the world fall in on you
with Wonder and joy and celebration but
if you're doing those things together to
gather gather gather and get can't can't
have more have more have more that you
just like you know you just want to get
as much as you can for yourself if
that's your prime motivation you're
going to be struggling every day for the
rest of your life rule number two
connect with your soul but if we ever
began to live our daily life from moment
to moment moving in side the wisdom of
our soul I just finished a book which
will be out in a few months
called the only thing that matters and
the only thing that matters argues for
the combining of the mind and the soul
in the consideration of our daily
choices and decisions see the mind holds
nothing but experience which it imagines
to be knowledge knowledge
that experience is not knowledge it's
simply experience and your experience
can be warped by all manner of things
knowledge true knowledge is held in the
soul eternal wisdom is held in the soul
so our job as human beings is to find a
way to marry the minds experience with
the souls knowledge and to come to a
place in between when a person does that
there's they're said to have been
centered you're really centered in that
place between the mind and the soul all
great mystics have found that place you
know they don't just reject the mind
altogether because the minds experience
is valuable if I didn't know about the
minds experience I would I would touch a
hot pan on the stove and burn myself or
put my hand in the socket and get a
shock or walk off the edge of a cliff so
my experience my mind is it is a good
friend and I'm not saying we should
reject our mind but all the true mystics
and masters have found a way to marry
the mind of the soul rather than to
lived exclusively in the mind to the
exclusion of the soul if I would if I
had one piece of advice for human beings
it would be connect with your soul find
a way to connect with your soul every
day not once a week when you go to
church or synagogue or temple but if you
even do that but every single day how do
you recommend people connect well
there's a thousand ways to do that
meditation guided imagery visualization
ecstatic dance the whirling dervishes do
it all the time you know reading good
poetry the praying you know there's a
thousand ways but it starts just
willingness you must be willing you must
say okay God or life or whatever word
you want to use that's comfortable to
you
I'm here and I'm willing I'm willing to
be quiet for a moment
each day with my soul if you do that
often enough and regularly enough
ultimately you'll discover an opening
something happens and it's not just a
flash but it occurs on a regular basis
rule number three see life for what it
is but I think what creates anger is the
mind thinking that what is going on
should not be going on that's something
else should be happening so the mind
starts looking at what's happening is
saying it shouldn't be like this
God darn it it shouldn't be like this
I'm getting pretty mad this shouldn't be
like this
don't argue with life it's it is what it
is and when we stop arguing with life
and see it for what it is see here's
what here's to tie it all together
Lilu when I was down the street for a
year toward the end of that time not the
beginning I went through a lot of anger
like you're talking about and a lot of
frustration and disappointment but
finally I got to a place where I
realized I see what this is all about I
see what this is
this whole experience that I'm having
has been given to me by life as an
opportunity for me to really get clear
on what's important and Who I am and why
I'm really here on the earth and I was
so stubborn about it for me I had to be
hit over the head with a two-by-four I
had a really loose everything lose my
family lose my house lose my job lose my
income I even all I almost lost my life
what threw me on the street was I was in
an automobile accident in which I had my
neck broken now you know most people
with a broken neck godd lesson don't
live you break your neck you die and if
you don't die at the very least you're
paralyzed from here down for life god
bless those folks
somehow or another I escaped both they
didn't die and I wasn't paralyzed but I
broke my neck sure as we're sitting here
but I just in the right place you know
one
is off and the doctors said you know
it's you're so lucky you're just
amazingly lucky that's your neck snapped
in a place where it wasn't crucial and
there aren't rape there are many places
like that in your neck but you you you
escaped
now having escaped death having escaped
life as a as a paraplegic and having
found yourself on the street with
nothing to your name one pair of shoes
one pair of pants three shirts having
gone through all that what's really
important rule number four my personal
favorite fully express yourself
ninety-eight percent of the world's
people are spending ninety-eight percent
of their time on things that don't
matter on things that have nothing to do
with why we're here
if we get caught up in our doing this oh
you don't understand I'm a camera man
that's what I do I'm I'm an audio
technician that's what I do no you don't
understand I I do interviews you know I
write books that's what I do
but those doing this functions are
meaningless unless they are ways to
demonstrate what we're really here to
accomplish and what we're really here to
accomplish is the fullest expression of
who we really are people who step into
that activity and come from that
awareness are people who change the
lives of everyone whose life they touch
rule number five wake up one of the
biggest mistakes that people make is
thinking that the the things they're
doing that they're required to do them
when in fact they're making a free
choice to do that there are plenty of
people who don't work there are people
who actually abandoned their families
rather than work
there's so unhappy you know in their
life that they just chuck it all and
walk away from it so the problem with
humanity is we keep on making a series
of free choices and then we call
ourselves the victims of our own choices
so what I say to people of my audience
is if you don't want to go to work and
support your family then don't who's
making you do that who told you how to
do that
oh I just can't walk away why not people
do it all the time I'm not saying it's
the right thing to do I'm saying but
when you do what you claim to be the
right thing of your own free choice and
then you claim you yourself to be the
victim of doing the right thing then
your disowning your own self your
disowning your own choices for heaven's
sake if you're gonna do what you think
is right at least be proud of it don't
don't look don't let yourself talk
yourself into that you're the victim of
it what does that say about you if
you're the victim of it what does that
say about you you know well I'm only I'm
only supporting my family and paying my
bills and doing what's right because I
have no choice what's that say about you
no no of course you have choice there's
no such thing as no choice so I say to
people let's understand that what this
statement means there's nothing you have
to do there's nothing we have to do is
God's Way of telling us it's another
it's another way of saying you have free
choice always about everything but for
goodness sakes stop making free choices
and call yourself the victim of them
wake up notice what's happening
every act is an act of self definition
everything we do defines who we are but
we shouldn't you know do all these
wonderful things that define who we are
and then fail to lay claim to them
reject them call them not our own rule
number six know who you really are
because a lot of people walk with masks
and try to please others well they do
when living authentically seems like a
really important thing of course it is
if people are trying to please others
it's because they do not know who they
really are when you know who you really
are and have chosen to step into the
living of that the idea of pleasing
someone else becomes less and less
useful to you less and less attractive
less and less beneficial because too
often in order to please someone else
you have to abandon who you really are
and betrayal of yourself in order not to
betray another mm-hm is betrayal
nonetheless mm-hm
it's the highest betrayal mm-hm so we
learned that as we get older and we
learned that oh I'm not going to betray
myself anymore
rule number seven transform fear the
biggest problem on the planet today is
fear it's been a problem for a long time
but it's a huge problem now it's getting
bigger every day and the reason that
fear is problem of course is that it
affects everything everything we think
and say and do all the decisions and
choices we make all of our reactions all
of our responses everything that we're
experiencing can come from only one of
two places conversations with God has
made that very clear to me
we're either coming from love where
we're coming from fear and my
observation is that most people most of
the time and myself more than I would
like to acknowledge coming from fear so
we have to look at our fears and find
out what is fear anyway what is it all
about what are we afraid of and what
impact is it have
and the choices and decisions and the
creations for which we have made
ourselves responsible by the way that's
one of the first fears that there is the
fear of being responsible the fear of
placing yourself in a position of
responsibility for all that we are
creating so fear is the first aspect of
the human experience as I understand it
that we need to work very hard to heal
and I might even say to transform you
transform fear and you transform the
world rule number eight focus on the
right things you can't get to the top of
Mount Everest if you're deep-sea diving
so you so if you try to do one thing but
doing another obviously you can't
accomplish it so the reason that we
can't accomplish what we say we want is
that we what we say we want is the wrong
thing we're after the wrong thing if we
were truly understood the real reason
and purpose of life we would be wanting
and yearning for and seeking to achieve
what we came here to achieve while we
came to the planet to begin with it is
what what human life is all about and
what we don't understand is if we did
that if we just retrained our focus to
what it is we really were designed to
achieve all the rest would fall in on us
without effort all the things we think
we want peace health safety security
opportunity love joy all the rest would
automatically show up in our lives
without without any effort on our part
rule number nine go with the flow if
you're in the middle of difficulties and
problems how can you feel gratitude and
the answer is you've got to fight to
find the gift even in the difficult
that's what I was talking about earlier
when you shift your perspective from the
perspective of the mind because I want
to tell you something life will never
make sense to your mind if you're trying
to get life to make sense with your mind
you might as well forget it because life
will never make sense to your mind
because mind is very logical and life is
not so so in order for life to make
sense you've got to be I mean it's
literally out of your mind
and you've got to be into your soul and
when you begin to see life from the
perspective of your soul then even in
the midst as I was saying earlier even
in the midst of the worst of it you can
see the gift and what you can see the
gift then you can say thank you God so
thank you God for this gift which I
would not have been able to perceive had
I not embraced the perspective of the
soul but now I see well even this
horrible situation is bringing to me I
even see that but again I want to say so
this is important because when you see
that when you see the gift and begin to
move into gratitude the very shift the
shift away from resisting to gratitude
changes the exterior energies such that
the situation itself improves sometimes
automatically without you doing anything
I have a favorite thing that I like to
say life will resolve itself in the
process of life itself if you simply
appreciate life itself
so what I've learned to do is to just go
with the fall I hate this track beyond
belief but it's true mm-hmm just let the
river go by stop try to make the river
go where you think the river is supposed
to go and rule number ten the last time
before a very special bonus clip is be
divine fish something quite
extraordinary going on here most of us
don't even know what it is we don't know
what it's
we don't even know it's happening but it
is happening every moment of every
minute of every hour of every day it's
happening it's life
happening all around us and here's what
not very many people really fully and
deeply understand much less appreciate
it's happening for a reason there's a
purpose behind it
there's a mechanism in place there's a
process that's being undertaken in life
by in life itself and that process is
the process by which we as the livers of
this life as those who are living into
the experience create the experience we
are living into as a means of
experiencing and expressing who we
really are that life exists in all of
its forms the beauty of the night sky
the wonder of a garden of flowers the
incredible expression of humanity itself
the feeling of love and the glory of a
great idea which has just come to
someone and exploding within them and
awareness of something that they can't
even name but they can feel ah
they say that's me
even as they see the night sky they see
a part of themselves there there's a way
to relate even as they see the flowers
in a beautiful garden they can see
themselves there there's something of
beauty in me too and to look at this I'm
merely looking at myself in another form
and even as we look at other people we
can relate and we say there I go being a
human being wonderful being glorious
being divine there's something quite
extraordinary going on here it's a
process not only by which we experience
ourselves as divine but by which we
define what divinity is to us can you
imagine a process like this we're
actually creating God through the
process of being God as we are choosing
to create it that's what's happening
that's what's going on that's the
miracle of life itself flowing through
you in you as is you and once you
understand what's going on the purpose
of all of it the divine process you take
part in it in a brand-new way not
unconsciously but consciously not
unintentionally but intentionally not
accidentally but on purpose and you see
every golden moment of know as an
opportunity to recreate yourself anew in
the next grandest version of the
greatest vision you ever evolved about
who you are and if you do that only for
a short time for an hour a day an hour a
week an hour a month your whole life
will suddenly make sense to you
and you will touch the world
in a way that brings sense to the world
that's a life itself changes and becomes
the miracle it was intended to be and
human decide to be
the miracle healer intended to be
so beaut
being divided
I've got a very special bonus clip from
Neal on how to ask yourself the four
fundamental questions of life but before
that I want to know what did you learn
from this video what was the single
biggest lesson that you were going to
apply somehow to your life or your
business leave it down in the comments
below when you write it down as much
more likely to actually happen for you
so put it down in the comments thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love see you soon and enjoy the
bonus clip
so people go through their entire lives
without ever asking these extremely
powerful and fundamental questions
number one Who am I number two where am
I
that is what is this place that's called
physicality what am i where am i what is
this number three why am I where I am
why am I here and number four what is it
my opportunity to do about that what do
I intend to do about that now I'll give
you bite my answers and by the way one
when I say where am i don't mean where
am i right now in the supermarket or at
the train station or I don't mean that I
mean where am I in the broadest sense
that is what is this place this earth
this environment in the cosmos you know
where am I so how I would answer those
questions if I was looking into the
mirror right now Neil Who am I
I am an individual of divinity I make an
expression of God I am a singular
ization of the singularity
I am a derivation of the essential
essence I am to God as a wave is to the
ocean now I know when I say that
sometimes it sounds formulaic that is it
sounds like an answer and I've given a
thousand times before it sounds like a
formula answer but I'm sorry if it
sounds like an answer that I've given a
thousand times before because I have
given it a thousand times before I asked
myself this question all the time so but
when you internalize the answer what
it's not just saying something by rote
but saying something in a way that has
emotional content and meaning for you I
really am
a demonstration of divinity I really am
an individual of all that is an
individual of God that sets a context it
creates the contextual experience of my
identity my true self then I go to the
second question okay if that's who I am
then where am i what is this place that
I find myself in the answer for me is I
am in the realm of the relative where
things are relative to other things
where there's big and small fast and
slow up and down left and right here and
there before and after now and then good
and evil male and female so I am in the
realm of the physical where I have
physicalized because Who I am is not
physical its metaphysical the singular
ization of singularity that I am is a
soul or a spirit if you please but that
spirit has chosen to physicalize in the
realm of physicality so that I might
express an experience myself that's the
third question why am I where I am I am
in the realm of the physical because
that is the only aspect of the kingdom
of God it's all the kingdom of heaven
it's the only aspect of life the only
place within the life's spheres within
the realms of life where I can really
experience and express my true nature I
can't do it in the realm of the absolute
because in the realm of the absolute I
simply know who I am I always am divine
it's always here it's always now I am
always the experience and the expression
of love so I am always loved here and
now love here and now love here and now
that's all very lovely to know that but
I want to experience it I want to
express it so the expression of it is
what occurs when I'm in the realm of the
physical and that's why I'm in the realm
of the physical that's why I'm living my
life the way I'm living it because it's
giving me a chance to express my true
nature and the fourth question what is
it your opportunity to do about that
that question is answered in every
single moment in every golden moment of
now from one moment to the next each
moment will provide a stage upon which
you can act out
I want a sense not in the sense of
pretending but in the sense of simply
putting into action to act out your
decision and your choice about who you
are for instance right now because you
asked me this question this golden
moment gives me a chance to act out my
idea of who I am and my idea of Who I am
is that aspect of divinity called
clarity I am clear about Who I am why
I'm here and what my opportunity is and
I'm demonstrating my clarity right now
that's how the whole formula works so
the first question and you say you want
to ask this to yourself once or twice a
quite price a day first question is Who
am I
second question is where am I the third
question is why am I here and the fourth
question is what am I going to do about
it
beautiful that's it it's a very simple
formula but it's very empowering because
you can ask yourself the question
anytime driving in the car standing in
the shower movies for the post office it
doesn't matter you can ask yourself
these questions and it becomes a mental
discipline to just check in and make
sure that you're on track and it gotten
haven't gotten lost in the labyrinth of
life where it starts to seem like you're
not who you are and it starts to seem
like you have no idea what's going on or
why it's happening more than one person
has spent a minute or two asking
themselves well why is this going on why
I don't understand why is this happening
to me
but if you stay connected to the four
fundamental questions of life those
questions go away raise your standard
Apple at the core is core values
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the way people now
one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top 10 most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details